بالعوده مشاهدينا الى تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا فمع اتهامات روسيا بل لكافه
بابعاد الانظار عما يحدث بعدها حادثه
بلغراد ترى موسكو في سقوط المدينه انتصارا
استراتيجيا اما بالنسبه لاوكرانيا ربما
تكون فرصه جديده فبحسب صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان ادعاء روسيا بتحقيق النصر يصدل
الستار عن اكثر المعارك دمويه في اوكرانيا
اما اوكرانيا فتقول بان هذه التطورات تمثل
فرصه مؤاتيه لاخذ زمام المبادره وقلب
الموازين المحيط بخمت وضواحيها التي
تحاصرها الان قوتكاز بخموت التي باتت
مدمره بشكل كامل بعد اشهر من القتال قد لا
تساعد بالضروره موسكو في تحقيق هدفها في
فرد السيطره الكامله على دومباس وفق
الصحيفه فالقوات الاوكرانيه ستكثف قصفها
لاماكن تمركز القوات الروسيه بالمدينه
فضلا عن الميزه التي سيفرضها استلام كاف
لمقاتلات حديثه مثل اف 16
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات